speedo una piccolissima anteprima di
quello che state per vedere ma piccole
piccole come basta basta allora quando
ho fatto l'ultimo gioco race game che è
stato ci si chiama così mi avete scritto
ma favi ma lo sai che i giochi red che
mi piacciono tantissimo era un po che
non li facevi farne altri che sono
proprio contento che gli ai portatili
sui regi game proprio in coincidenza è
facciamo le leggi che in ragazzi cazzo
mi devo dire stars game area 01 spiega
deve introdurre da tutti ragazzi mente
che sono video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
new haven seconds che significa che ai
10 secondi che ai 10 secondi 120 devi
raggiungere le cose in dieci secondi
bene non ho mai capito quanti i livelli
ci siano da qui alla fine però ok quindi
tu ai 10 secondi per finire livello una
figata
non faccio domande perché essendo un
rating dovrebbe fare incazzare se
sapessi raggiungere come cosa faccia a
faccia parte che perché sa perché in un
tot di vite dopo un po non puoi più
brava a [ __ ] el'orecchio e sta il
problema allora fermi in attivo cioè i
perché che cosa sono sti così attaccati
al muro tra l'altro anche ragazzi non
vale dove di spiegarvi come si gioca
sono con l'amica che ce la faccio quali
sono i tasti cosa devo fare qua io non
lo so se non me lo dite
ok perfetto bene cos'è veloce perfetto
lo sta riveda cos'è po santo iddio lo
brucio non solo dai ragazzi e vabbè ok
vai zio videsh io davo il jump che
figata se anche da voi già perfetto area
01 cleared perfetto acquisterà il
tutorial in poche parole ci sono 4 dopo
se ne sbloccando anche altre non lo so
ragazzi andiamo sulla 2a proprio ho
sbloccato il doppio salto per sempre
figata
ok ok molte vite mi sono rimaste zero se
muoiono a 38 c o nel culo perfetto
ottima notizia soprattutto saperla alla
fine dei livelli fantastico bene dai
ancorato livelli senza morire ce la puoi
fare zio che sono un [ __ ] per chi
vuole da riproviamoci papa ko ma non è
così difficile sto gioco non riesco a
farlo o ce l'ho fatta prima pasta rock
noi far incazzare zio neanche una volta
voglio morire in questi neanche mezza
[ __ ] la vita andiamo avanti lo
stesso chissenefrega
porca [ __ ] o miglia non è possibile
come facciano riuscirci appena tentativo
insomma una cagata ogni volta o è
veramente porca eva da altri o tua madre
veramente allora uno guarda le vite
le legge dice ok ho ancora tante vite
tempo un secondo e non c'è più un
secondo passa può anche esserci scritto
800mila lì sotto tanto in tre secondi le
perdi tutte facile arrivato però si cela
arrivato vai vai zio vai zio vai sì o
fatti valere
ma perché muore perché come il problema
a sono sì cose che mi fanno cadere
vancouver
no ragazzi impossibile c'è duro ci
arriverò mai all'arena 4 impossibile se
io non riesco a arrivare neanche a metà
figuriamoci come faccio a finirlo come
dovrei fare spiega spiega mi si chiede
una cosa cosa
ma cosa d'aiuto sorella in autostrada no
no ma no o ti ammazzo non mi prende per
il culo francia non mi prendere
veramente per i comuni giro in [ __ ]
serio è serio
so cero perfetto quanto tempo ci ho
messo al brand e quanto tempo ci ho
messo per perderlo io non capisco qual è
il tuo problema al cervello quale cazzo
è spiegami quale cazzo non capisco qual
è il tuo problema zio se non salti
questo problema
sì ha ringraziato gesù cristo un ora per
fare sta roba mica era solo quello
difficile poi scommettete [ __ ]
speriamo non morire non morire la moglie
che mi dovrei far tutto la morena che
magari fa tutto ok su livelli senza
morire devo fare [ __ ] e non ce la
farò mai ragazzi però va bene l'ultimo
ce la posso fare dai figlio ce l'ho
fatta
non lo so ha fatta quanti hanno fatto
manca non ho capito
ok non ho capito cosa è successo cosa
devo fare però va bene ce l'ho fatta
bene area 4 l'ultimo questa roba
io posso premere un tasto per utilizzare
il magnete ho capito cioè non ho ben
capito mi si usa per ora infatti non
funziona [ __ ] ha spiegato la bara
bassa che finiamo il suo contento guarda
che mi trasporta store o non muoio muoio
e basta perfetta come faccio che mi
trasporta sulle spine come faccio
spiegami come a ok perfetto c a metà
siamo a metà
vai vai fiorai zio e zia mica ce l'ho
fatta fin qua definire ragazzi ci ho
fatto figo a definire me ne frega niente
vai vai frate carico scarico frate
mancano due mancando eroica 2
non mi vedo arqiva ok ma da chi già
stava tornando dai stavo tornando sulle
spine vai zio vai zio vai zio perfetto
ne manca uno non è vero ma veramente ma
trovano solo ragazzi non ci posso
credere e quindi ho vinto
che cazzo di livello e questo cos'è
per questo 50 secondi e va bene cos'è
sta roba è l'unico nel quale si muove
tutto lo schermo tra porca put
tanto il timer ce l'ho in testa è
bellissimo
cioè se muoio quadro rifarmi tutto
daccapo vero zio grazie per carità e mi
sono fatto un culo per cosa vite zero
grazie di ricordarmi che 0 vinte brutto
stronzo
finché tensione dove devo andare qua giù
su ok non ho capito ma va bene vai vai
vai 0 ma cantiere fu chi disse tu
ambiente dove vado non vedo non vedo
vorrei fare il classico commento sulla
[ __ ] della serie che del sé tutta i miei
piedi però lo era già prima quindi cazzo
me ne cioè non ho avuto neanche rompere
la tastiera già è per te è un traguardo
per me ragazzi nel senso che in genere
finisce molto peggio cioè non che io non
l'abbia distrutta adesso è però meno del
solito ragazzi miei spero che questo
video vi sia piaciuto non siate mia no
non consigliatemi altri dei g20
ragazzuoli spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto cose sul momento e mi piace
anche i vari social che come è stato nel
schizzare se ne sono visti discreta ci
vediamo lo fosse un video è la ragazzi